your best theory is is that the Chinese
created a virus covid in order to try to
create a vaccine to oppose it to try to
see if they could create a vaccine that
would work for all Corona viruses the
person who was uh working on these
vaccines we know his name a general zo
yusen and he's developing this vaccine
sometime in 2019 but he has to have
somebody develop a mutant Corona virus
that actually infects humans well we
think that's what Co was was developed
in the lab to create the vaccine we also
know that zo got a vaccine and he has it
created by February of 2020 and most
people think there's no way you could
have gotten it that quickly unless he'd
been working on it for some time we also
know that this General dies mysteriously
two months later so there's a lot to be
said here that what was going on is a
creation of a virus creating a gain of
function Corona virus that would infect
humans easily and then uh creating a
vaccine from that and what happened is
that it accidentally got out of the lab
we also actually know the names of the
three scientists who got sick in
November of 2019 there we actually know
the name some people say these are the
patient zero and they got sick in N 2019
November and yet the Chinese didn't
admit to anything going on till January
and even in January second week of
January the Chinese are still saying oh
nothing to see here we don't think it's
transmittable between humans meanwhile
it's been cooking and growing for three
months and they knew that wasn't true
how should science funding in this
country change given the facts we've
learned through this discovery you know
this debate's been going on a long time
some scientist uh engineered Aven flu
and made it transmittable through the
air among mammals and people were very
concerned because Aven flu is very
deadly in humans but fortunately doesn't
infect humans very easily so they had a
big debate and they they shut down gain
of function research between 2014 and
2016 the only problem was Anthony fouy
kept giving exemptions to all the people
that were doing this research and then
in 2017 the pause uh on gain of function
funding expires and they set up a new
committee a pandemic pathogen committee
that's supposed to review things for
safety well all those things sound good
but then none of the Wuhan research ever
went before the committee in fact the
committee the chair of the committee
told me they only looked at three
projects out of probably possibly
hundreds of these gain of function um
grants that they were looking at so what
you end up having to have is I think you
probably need a committee of scientists
uh as well as people in the National
Security theater who are aware of what
kind of weapons can be made from these
viruses you need them looking at it and
trying to decide whether the taxpayers
should fund this I think rather than a
blanket ban of just saying no gain of
function the problem is if you say no
gain of function Anthony fouchy already
says all of these experiments which were
obviously gain of function were not so
he just defined finds himself out of the
rules and I think they'll continue to do
that but I think you need a committee
and the other thing about the committee
is it has to be independent they have to
be able to review Any Grant throughout
government and they also can't be the
same people getting the money so for
example this Christian Anderson who does
Fouch bidding to write a paper saying
nothing to see here he got a $9 million
Grant the next month so you can't have
the people involved with determining
whether something's safe also be getting
grants from the people that are uh
they're judging the safety of you can't
that that's too incestuous to be a real
oversight condition but we think it can
be done Our Hope still is that we could
get a bipartisan bill out of this we
continue to try to work with Democrats
every day to get them interested in the
issue the hardest part is just the lack
of curiosity the Democrats haven't
really cared much about this a million
Americans died and Democrats seem to be
Blas about doing anything about it you
also suggest in the book some sorts of
controls over the the actual materials
that are used in labs to manipulate
viruses or bacterias or you know other
uh life forms and you know we're we're
in the synthetic biology age now and in
some sense like the the the gatekeeping
is gone and it I I just wonder like um
how do you think about the tradeoffs
there in terms of not stifling
scientific progress while at the same
time making sure we don't have Rog
groups creating super viruses that cause
a global pandemic you know most research
goes through universities and through uh
Grant agencies giving to the
universities and so I think that can be
policed through a some sort of Safety
Committee application of judging what is
safe and what is not safe but we live in
an era you're right an era era of
synthetic biology you can order on the
internet the RNA uh to create the polio
virus you can literally get on the
internet right now and order the the
bits of it if you know how to put it
together you can create the polio virus
from nothing it's almost as if you're
creating life now a virus may not really
be life because it has to live in a
living cell but essentially you're
creating something that you can put into
and basically bring alive from nothing
so I think there should be some rules on
ordering this you know we don't let you
buy centrifuges online we don't let you
enrich uranium in your basement um this
is I think equivalent to to nuclear
weapons and how many people can die from
this and so even being a Libertarian and
not believing in many government rules
this is one of the exceptions that I
think government could participate in
the other thing is is since government
funds so much of this even as a
Libertarian there's no real restriction
on how much you want to regulate
government or regulate the expenditure
of government funds so I think there
needs to be a great deal more done to
this and probably 95 to 99% of it will
be government funds that need to be uh
regulated more strictly hey thanks for
watching that clip from my conversation
with Rand Paul you can watch another
clip right here or the full conversation
over here